we're talking about 11 year old baton
twirler Annabella Atkinson she's a
superstar she and her mom have moved
from the studio to the parking lot here
at 8 news now and that's where John and
Heather are this morning we're following
along with them so we are out here this
morning so excited to see Annabella
perform a little bit more this is the
Good Day Las Vegas performance space
here this is our studio this is our
dance studio our twirling studio so
Annabella we've been seeing some of your
moves are these some of the things that
you're going to be competing in in the
in the competition coming up in August
yes okay so a lot of the baton twirling
yes a lot of the batons really I was
going to ask you what do you like most
about this stuff I like what I like most
about baton twirling is you get to
perform in front of the judges and show
off your personality and I get to make a
lot of friends okay throughout the
country and and Sherry asked in the
commercial break by the way with with a
whole family of baton tours you haven't
broken anything in the house right the
lamps are in good shape the dishes the
the table tops are all good yes okay but
there's been some deep sea swimming pool
diving I think for the Baton okay
Annabella let's have you take it away
let's see your moves
you can add your own John Philip Sousa
band music in the background
look at that
Nate what do you think you think you
pull some of this off yourself Mr
Tannenbaum Oh sure yeah I taught
Annabella everything she knows
now she explained earlier flexibility
her her competition is she can't let the
Baton out of her hand for this
particular competition but she often
does toss it up and catch it right
Heather
right and she was telling me here
outside you know so much of that
Foundation comes from ballet so you have
to have that perfect dance Foundation
Annabella you are amazing wow what a way
to end this show here on this Thursday
thank you very much for coming in we
appreciate it all right